do you see that cnn article that was
like inflation is good for poor people
and bad for rich people
it's it's look it's it's the hunger
games for everyone that article uh but
it's substantially worse for the poor
that's right that article was i'm like
watching the hunger games and stanley
tucci sitting up on stage going don't
worry inflation is bad for the rich
people
i'm like if you're rich you can convert
your your scary good by the way yeah
that's scary if you're rich you can
convert your cash into real estate into
gold into bitcoin into hard assets and
if you're poor you can't it's or should
say that's right you can't it's just
substantially harder so every day your
bank account has lower and lower buying
power rich people are like about a
painting yeah exactly well and
interestingly enough inflation is
literally as flat as attacks can get
everyone loses the exact same percentage
of spending power off of every dollar
they have you made a point earlier about
not being able to uh multiply wealth by
dividing it and i think there's one
exception and i believe you'll agree
with it based on what you've said but
there is one way to multiply wealth by
dividing it which is just through
voluntary trade and people who own their
own businesses making the decision to
spend in specific places so that their
money goes to somebody's making a
product that adds wealth to the economy
but when it comes to the federal
government doing it they're completely
inept you could to grow wealth by
dividing it like one way be like if
you're with a bunch of people in a tribe
and they don't have shoes but you need
to go hunting you could give give
everybody a little
pair of shoes of yours that's
distributing your wealth and now they
can all go hunting and they're going to
be better at it and so that's that's
called an investment though that's
exactly right so that's the difference
so giving but i gave them money and
that's also done by the people and for
the people you know it's not government
basically just printing out dollars for
their own agendas
but let me let me give you a better
example i do like where you're at on
this idea you know that that you could
have a bunch of shoes give them out and
then everyone is better off but the
problem is what our government is doing
is a tribe of people and one guy has you
know five pairs of shoes everybody else
has one and there's one guy with no
shoes so the chief comes in takes four
of the pairs of shoes from the rich guy
and then sells them to pay for pakistani
gender studies yeah well 25 million
actually but but right remember that was
technically though this is why i love
let me tell you the democrats have
gotten brilliant about the labeling of
bills and and like for example the bill
you're talking about the america rescue
bill where 25 million dollars goes to
pakistan for gender research programs
how does that help the average america i
know myself i was sitting at home
thinking god i really wish my money
could go to gender research in pakistan
yeah yeah i was really concerned and
here's the question that nobody asks
about this kind of thing
in some circumstances you might be able
to argue that foreign aid is a
legitimately charitable thing to do but
can you name a single country that went
from a developing country to a developed
country because the united states
government threw enough money at it when
has it ever worked well in afghanistan
yeah yeah look at that
yeah wow
that's a touchy one i mentioned it to
thomas massey i was like why don't we
just instead of giving a borrowing from
the federal reserve giving it to another
country why don't they just borrow it
from this from the reserve but what i
should have said is just why don't they
borrow it from their own central bank
and leave us out of it and then accrue
their own debt why do we have to they
want money they don't have so like in
the instance of a
instance of afghanistan they don't have
the resources or wealth to trade with
other countries for advanced technology
and development well but what about
china who just came in there and they're
looking to harvest 1.3 trillion of
lithium and who are they going to sell
those renewable batteries back to
america yeah yeah so i mean again there
there all of these countries have for
the for the most part something i mean
people are like oh well what do they
have in uh kenya or somalia well they
got oil you know we saw that in lake
lake turkana around that area so you
know it's the same thing with
afghanistan you know they're like oh
it's nothing but rocks well it's got 1.3
trillion dollars first off in in lithium
not to mention that it's got one of the
most mineral-rich areas for rubies and
emeralds in in the entire country and
who's who's harvesting it china why
don't we invade alaska
music it's kind of the joke we have you
know when we have jack bosovic here or
like daniel turner they're they're both
like invade alaska i mean there's
tremendous resources there why don't we
do it why don't we why don't we use our
own sources this is the funniest part we
always talk about you know the left
again the left always talks about
climate and environmental you know
things like this but we're one of the
most environmentally friendly like
nations that you can think of i mean we
are exceptionally responsible with our
harvesting principles we are
exceptionally responsible i mean look
one of the best examples i have people
in florida were attacking the u.s sugar
and some of these companies saying that
they were actually destroying the
waterways they weren't talking about
runoffs and spill offs like that they
pointed it to the fingers of agriculture
what they didn't look at is that this
same company
over generates their refineries 25 000
kilowatts and gives it back to the
actual people but so so we're one of the
most responsible but yet we'll go and
buy an import from china russia and all
the others who have the least
responsible way of harvesting and then
we're okay with that again it's like
your food analogy right it's like why
would you kill that animal why don't you
just go to the store where you know no
animals were harmed exactly i mean
that's that's exactly what we're looking
at great man we want to prevent
ourselves in america from being able to
do things which we do more responsibly
but we're going to turn a blind house
down abroad it's a big trick it's a
hypocrisy so a lot of people complained
about trump the trump administration
removing environmental protections for
companies and they didn't realize was
that was because it was bringing
companies it was the only way to bring
companies back to the united states so
pros and cons i mean you can say it's a
bad thing by all means you're free to
say so i'm not saying it's a good thing
that's why he did it
when we say to a company you've got to
spend more on your minimum wage when we
say we're going to raise your taxes
when we say we're going to regulate you
to make it impossible for you to work
and then we say but any product you make
overseas can enter this country with no
taxes what do you think those companies
are going to do and by the way i'm going
to be like china i would completely
abolish the epa
let me let me just tell you as a
business owner they literally were i
wanted to create a a training facility
for one of the law enforcement
departments right and they were they had
someone who came out and did an
environmental study to make sure that
there was no ferns or any type of like
protected thing out there right so they
said oh no no you can't build here and
then all of a sudden out of the blue
they were like unless you pay this 60
000
environmental credit
and then we'll allow you to do it i mean
look it's the biggest scheme in the
world i mean i had to actually ask the
epa for permission to build on my land
that i owned that i was donating back to
the law enforcement department to be
able to train on and then had to pay a
60 000 credit and in the meantime
glyphosate there's there's studies and
evidence that it's causing cancer and
farmers and but monsanto somehow is now
using it okay it's it's a it's an
herbicide or it's a fungicide and it
kills bugs basically so they're spraying
all these crops with this roundup now
they're using it as a desiccant meaning
before the vegetables are ready to be
harvested they're not dry so they spray
it with roundup to dry them out and then
they harvest it talk about unethical or
practices
agriculture practices we have this
wonderful organic system you got to pay
massive amounts of money to get your
stuff registered through and then
they're they're desiccating our crops
with
toxin i've i've heard these stories you
know like you were mentioning about uh
the fee and everything i was watching a
video
where uh a guy apparently was was
working on his own land and then one day
someone shows up and said you have to
stop the development of you know your
property because we saw a bird
they said you know i've even had them
have to come you had to pay money to
destroy
and properly return the land back to
what it was prior to your building wow
because they saw a certain kind of
tortoise in the area or
in in florida for example not only do
you have to go through the epa
roundabout but then they have to do an
ancestral study to make sure that there
was no native americans who had at one
point i mean they find a an arrowhead or
something they're like oh no no this was
an ancestral land therefore you can't
build yeah but like everything is
you know either there's there's uh
reasonable development
or there's no or there's or there's none
i think reasonable development of any
land includes real environmental
protections obviously like we don't want
you dumping waste in the rivers and
things like that when you're building a
septic system you'll need like the you
know um you need the bits et cetera what
is it called what's the field the leech
field you'll need a leech field and all
that stuff you know you got to make sure
it's not running off on someone's
property but when they can abuse their
power the government does and they are
the um you got the uh what are they
called neonicotinide pesticides which
are now there's evidence that it's
disrupting the the bees are like getting
it in their system and then they can't
find their way and then they die off and
they think that's causing colony
collapse disorder it's really
irresponsible for the environmental
protection agency to be giving monsanto
this kind of power which is now bayer
bear purchased monsanto because they
wanted to get rid of the bad press from
the name
that sounds like a 20 to me thank you
yeah
well this is what people fail to realize
whenever you have these large government
agencies coming around to regulate any
sector of the economy they just end up
in the pocket of the highest bidder so
of course monsanto is going to get away
with everything they're doing and then
for some reason when you criticize the
big corporations that are ripping us off
and the government that's selling us out
to them
you're the fascist no no now you're a
domestic terrorist oh yeah remember i
mean
they up the ante on this now i mean even
poor parents who are just wanting a
balanced curriculum in their
neighborhoods or domestic terrorists i
mean this this has been that's crazy
something that they're just throwing out
and this is this is why though i think
virginia turned red and i believe this
because kitchen table issues you know
parents have a right you know i'm a
father so i've got two boys 17 and seven
and so i can tell you right now do i
care about my child's curriculum you're
damn right i do and these teachers
unions are running like the epa or any
of the other big government and they're
just saying well it's our way or the
highway and if you oppose it
well you're a domestic terrorist yeah
that's what i like is when you oppose
the government and then all of a sudden
you're considered evil because you
oppose or you're put on a watch list
yeah a government it's a fascist
government well let's yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you